when I was single I actually ended up
eating at Chipotle over 500 times and I
found out only from my accountant when
he looked at my financials and he was
like is this mistake you ate 500 times
at Chipotle and I was like well it's
lunch and dinner 10 times a week yeah
that makes sense and I like Chipotle
because I could get 100 grams of protein
each sitting when I was trying to get as
many calories in as possible I would
have two tortillas which were free each
of those were 400 calories a pop I would
get a bag of chips which was 700
calories and then I would have a bowl
that had double rice double beans double
meat which would be a pause double so
I'd go half and half chicken steak
because you get like one and a half each
time and then I'd be like actually you
know what let's make it a double and
then they would put another half and
half and when they do that they usually
give you like a three quarter three
quarter so it ended up being like a
triple meat and then I would have Pico
lettuce sour cream and I did that every
day and it was just because it was
cheaper for me than buying groceries and
so I did it that way and it saved me so